[Music]
I'm Rita Hana and I'm part of the
orangey DNA pipelines team here at the
Sanger Institute my job is to test and
develop new methods to sequence DNA a
DNA pipeline is the process of taking
DNA samples preparing them for
sequencing and sequencing them before
releasing the data to the researcher
because we work with DNA samples and
sometimes those samples have very low
amount of DNA we need to make sure that
we will never contaminate them with our
own DNA and that's why we wear lab coats
and gloves all the time we receive the
samples in 96-well plates and I've
already been extracted and purified from
cell tissue or blood when we receive
those samples we need to check the
quality of the DNA to check that it's
still very long strength of genomic DNA
that's what we call the quality control
or QC step we really don't want to waste
a lot of the sample for quality control
that's why we are using the mosquito
robots for that step because it's able
to be pet only nanoliters of DNA these
nano liters of DNA pitted by the robot
are then mixed with a solution
containing a fluorescent dye these
molecules of dye grow very very bright
only when they touch DNA so we can
relate the level of fluorescence with
the actual concentration of DNA in the
sample then when we are sure that how
DNA is of good quality and in good
amounts we start the library
construction itself this take place in
our pre PCL lab on the Bravo robots the
Bravo robot will be able to peep at some
solution containing what we call
adapters those adapters are very short
fragment of DNA that get attached or
ligated to the end of audio samples the
adapters have two goals they will load
the sample to attach at the surface of
the flow cell and they also contain a
tag that will be part of our sequencing
data and with all of us to
know which fragments of DNA came from
which sample because we process such a
high number of samples we need to make
sure that we never exchange them or lose
them and that's why we use barcodes on
each of our plates we have a process
called limbs for laboratory information
management system which allow us to scan
all those barcodes and track the samples
all along the library preparation
process after attaching the adapters to
a DNA fragment we take the samples off
the robot deck onto a bench because we
are sharing those benches with a lot of
people in the lab they need to remain
very tidy and clean so we have divided
the space with tape and labels so that
we know exactly where things are the
samples are now ready for PCR
amplification and during this process we
have to heat the sample to high
temperature to avoid evaporation we seal
the plates with a very tight seal PCR
amplification has to be done in a
different lab to avoid
cross-contamination and we pass the
sample through a special hatch between
those two labs each lab has different
colors of lab coats to make sure that we
are not contaminating samples between
the labs we then take the samples and
put them in a PCR machine that is able
to amplify the DNA the DNA samples are
now ready for sequencing and in order to
be loaded on the sequencer we need to
remove the seal now that's quite a
tricky step despite the fact that it
looks very simple and no robots can do
it it has to be done by hand to avoid
splashes between the samples which would
lead to cross-contamination the samples
are then put on a flow cell loaded on
the sequencer and the sequencing run can
start
during a run we can check on the monitor
of each sequencer the quality of the
data being created and check that
everything is working fine on the
sequencer when a sequencing run is
finished the data is transferred to a
data center which is a huge cluster of
computers the last stage for pipelines
team is to check that we have produced
enough data and of good quality and when
that last check is done the researchers
that have initially requested the
sequencing are able to access the data
in the cluster I really like working in
the DNA pipelines because it use a lot
of different skills I studied chemistry
and then I work in a biophysics lab so
that's why I particularly like it it's
always exciting and never boring
[Applause]
[Music]
you